foreign
let's go to Elena oh in Oklahoma Okay
Oklahoma I'm gonna smile Elena in
Oklahoma and Tulsa what's up hey this is
really surreal it is super surreal for
me but this is crazy good to have you
yeah like a month ago listening to you
live for the first time with every
dollar convention now here I am pretty
crazy oh yeah you were you in Oklahoma
uh we no we were in Dallas we drove down
there for the to be there on that
Saturday oh that's super fun that was a
fun day huh yeah it was pretty awesome
pretty awesome so that's very cool so
what's up how can I help
all right so I feel like it kind of
boils down to
um I feel like I just lose my mind with
my husband constantly I've been here up
in here yelling always like controlling
telling him what to do nagging and he's
recently been like hey you know can you
chill and stop following me around I
I can't figure it out it's like every
time uh you know something comes up like
can you do the dishes can you do like
vacuum the floors I just go ballistic
wow why what does that get you it gets
you something what does it get you
a feeling of control I don't know
I guess that's kind of it's um
I guess we whenever we first got married
we really struggled he kind of didn't
know like how to help around the house
because I did a lot of it there's a lot
of uptake and uh in the beginning I
really did have to kind of encourage and
tell them what to do because his
response was I just can't see it like I
don't know when the things are dirty I
don't see the carpet and you see
vacuumed I don't think of like mopping
the kitchen floor and you know a lot has
changed in the past like year and a half
but um I still can't like relinquish
that he'll get it done maybe not this
instant
like he'll do it
this has absolutely zero to do with him
no zero
so here's my question for you you ready
and you're not gonna like it that's okay
it's okay we're friends
um
and you feel free to be like eh you're
an idiot you're wrong but I don't think
I am okay okay
when you were a young little girl
you either grew up in a system where you
had no control at all
or it was a super chaotic environment
or the way you found control or kept dad
from screaming or kept mom from getting
off the rails or whatever was order
tell me I'm wrong this soon am I right
or wrong
yeah I know uh so I come from
um a lot of trauma in my childhood some
of it was related to my parents as long
as it was sexual abuse when I was really
young
um but I grew up in a lot of like
screaming and yelling from Dad and I
guess it was really confusing yeah and
now here I am doing the same thing and I
just can't
get rid of it and then um hold on hold
on hold on hold on
your dad's screaming and yelling
was because he had a little boy
that was still trying to protect him
and I'm not giving him a pass okay at
all
your response to your husband is that of
a kid
and that tells me you have a child who's
still trying to keep you safe
because somebody had to keep you safe
because the adults in your life sure as
hell weren't doing it
in fact they were the ones hurting you
and that little girl learned some
techniques and tricks
to keep on some sort of path because
nobody was helping her along
point you've got to make peace with that
little girl
and you've got to let her stop fighting
all your battles you gotta let her know
I'm all right now
I'm an adult now
so is that the kind of thing I can you
know go to my parents for and like maybe
share with him no they cashed out they
cashed out
they cashed out
yeah this conversation this starts with
you right writing your number one if
you've never talked to somebody about
your childhood sexual abuse you need to
do that
so we did we went to court all that
Shenanigans no yeah but that's you're a
tooled that point
you were somebody else's you were an
attorney's tool you're a uh cause for
your parents
did you go talk to a counselor
do you talk to a play therapist
yeah I did but it's it's been a while
and I hated it every single time do you
have little kids
no we're expecting I'm uh pregnant with
our first they'll be here in May so when
was uh when did your sexual abuse start
um when I was eight or six sorry
don't worry
I'm at 11. okay so uh what are you
having a boy or girl
we don't know yet we don't know until
December waiting for the anatomy scan so
that's made me really anxious the
anatomy scan you couldn't have said that
grosser the anatomy
I have to say it to myself because I
keep wanting to go buy like the blood
prick test and find out like tomorrow
we're like we're AI children
um
so there's a part of your body that
knows you're bringing a kid in the kid's
not going to be safe
yeah okay I already feel kind of
controlling every
a real one who they're with your body
has been out of control your whole life
and you have tried to make peace with
that through order through control
through Straight A's my guess you
probably made great grades through you
are a on time at work and you are so
pissed off when people are late like me
who comes just strolling in
and you just solve things because I'm
gonna I'm gonna you're gonna take all
the variability out of every single
interaction relational or otherwise
because that's how you're gonna stay
safe
and that is how you're gonna squash joy
laughter sleep
rambunctious great connected sex
because of this constricted hold on
everything and if you let go of this if
you feel like you let go
use control everything and this little
girl has worked too hard to lose control
and then when your ding dong husband who
loves you like crazy right
yeah comes Walton through and just plops
down and grabs a video game controller
and doesn't even see the pile of
underwear didn't he didn't see it
the only emotion you have is nine years
old
and it comes out in Rage
or nagging you know who nags my kid
young kids can I have a snack can I have
ice cream why can't I have it why the
dog's not walking with
and now you're an adult does that make
sense
yeah okay so here's what I want you to
do number one I want you to get back in
touch with the counselor okay okay let
them know that you are had systemic like
over three four five six years worth of
childhood sexual abuse
ended up in a court hearing all this
mess you had a raged out angry father
and God knows about your mom and dad and
his relationship and all that kind of
stuff
but let your counselor know you're about
to have a baby
and a lot of things are starting to
resurface
okay that's number one
you will feel a heightened sense of
relief and a heightened sense of anxiety
when you make that appointment
okay just expect that
you're going to go the first meeting and
you're going to hate it you're not going
to feel good about it because what
you're doing is you're relinquishing the
control you've held so tightly for so
long and I want you to feel that you
hate it and go anyway
okay that's the hardest part yes you are
practicing letting go of the steering
wheel and finding out the car is not
going to crash
okay that's what we're practicing here
the second thing is I want you to write
that nine-year-old girl a letter
nine-year-old Elena gets a letter
okay that says Dear Elena I'm so sorry
this was never your job
to defend yourself against dad
to wonder why Mom wasn't showing up for
you
why somebody sexually abused you and why
I was allowed to go on when everybody
kind of knew something was up
and I want you to write 14 year old
Elena a letter
because 14 15 16 17 18 year old Elena
went through hell didn't she
pretty much
she needs to be off the hook too
and what we're going to do is we're
going to systematically
teach our body that if we let our hands
off the wheel the whole thing doesn't
crash
we're going to systematically teach our
body that the little girl who's been
protecting us for all these years can
finally go play
which is what she should have been able
to do so many years ago
and then here's the third thing
when you yell
you stop yourself stop
just stop and let your husband know in a
moment when y'all aren't mad at each
other
or you're not mad at him
I am going to consciously stop yelling
I'm gonna quit
because I'm going to be a mom that
doesn't yell
I'm gonna be a mom that doesn't yell
I'm going to be a wife that doesn't nag
and so what that means is you're going
to have to learn how to say your needs
out loud in Crystal clearness like
crystal clearness that's not even a word
and very very clear in HD okay
and instead of saying like
um
hey you need to clean the bathroom you
need to clean the garage you need it
instead of that
it's a very calm and quiet
when I come home and you're sitting on
the couch playing video games and the
laundry's not done
I feel in my body
you're telling me through your behavior
because behavior is a language you're
telling me I don't care about her
yeah I don't love her
not enough to vacuum
that makes you feel really crazy like it
does like a mind game it does but listen
it's a game that only you're playing he
doesn't even know a game he doesn't know
and you can go down a rabbit hole if his
mommy didn't train him and all that
that's a waste of time
because here because we're here now
and he deserves the right for you to be
very clear about what you need not about
how he's failing and what a loser he is
and how he doesn't even that's not what
he needs because his defense mechanisms
go up when he goes under attack they
should
he needs to hear the best way to love
his wife
and when he doesn't here's how that
feels here's what it does to your body
and what you're gonna have to do is feel
for the first time in a long time
something other than
uh rage anger
disappointment frustration
yeah is that fair
yeah and then I I kind of I had
n't figured out too because that's that
covered a lot again really surprised you
picked up like one sentence
um when we first got married he was
military and he was a pretty severe
alcoholic and so I dealt with a lot of
like uh you know food language being
shoved around and pushed aside and like
it was a constant fight of like can you
please stop drinking and then uh it's
been almost a year since he stopped
because he didn't show up on her at one
one night home and so I pretty much told
him it's either like me or your beer and
I just can't let go of of that version
of him it's like all the time I see him
and I just feel like he's that's still
there and I'm just kind of like waiting
for it to come back and waiting for him
to you know call me names or like get
really drunk one day and just go off the
walls and
you know he reassures me that's not
gonna happen but I just
it almost becomes it
hey your body's just do it your body's
working great
is taking care of you exactly as it
should
because your dad shouldn't have yelled
and screamed too
yeah and your mom should have shown up
for you
and your body recognizes when people
show up and say they love Elena that's
when the hurt starts
and so you got right back in you married
your unfinished business and you were
gonna fix another man and that guy was
angry and dealing with his own PTSD
stuff and he was drinking and he was
abusive
and your brain put a GPS pin in him too
not safe
but since this is what we deserve and we
have a plan for this it's called control
we'll just go down that road right
because your body never even occurred to
you that you're worth more than this
because you've never ex you can talk
about peace and oh my gosh well look at
that guy in The Bachelor he seemed so
sweet you've never felt that
yeah right not really so has he quit
drinking
yeah yeah it's been almost a year when's
the last time he put his hands on you
over a year ago okay
have you all gone to counseling to
figure out how to build a new
relationship on the back of that
no yeah I've brought it up a lot of
times
you have to good
tell them how do I get him to go
tell him you're interested in building
something new
yeah
an entirely new marriage and that is
different than we need to go so I can
quit getting mad at you for how you used
to drink and hit me like that's you see
what I'm saying he's gonna lock up
mm-hmm the same as if he came to you and
said I we need to go to counseling
because you quit nagging me and whatever
and then boom you're Off to the Races
yeah we have both everyone's got defense
mechanisms built in for that moment
when the relationship gets threatened
boom we have our own responses
based on genetics life experience any
whatever's worked in the past
so it's not about him
it's about you
honey I want to be the wife that my dad
didn't have
and I want to love you recklessly and
I've got to learn to trust you again
because you hit me
yeah I've got to learn to love you again
because you're a scary alcoholic
and I trust that you're different but
I've got to learn some new skills I'm
asking you to come to a marriage
counselor with me and spend some time
learning some new skills with me
and if he looks at you and says no
that's stupid
your relationship has much bigger issues
and then what what if that is what he
says that's like I just
I don't know I just get really scared
that uh here's a deal man
we avoid the or what conversation all of
us do
yeah I'm not gonna tell my boss I can't
keep working 90 hour weeks or my wife's
Gonna Leave Me
or he might so we say nothing and she
leaves
I'm not going to tell my husband who's
abusive that if he hits me one more time
because because then what and so we just
say nothing
foreign
I need you to hear me Elena I need you
to hear me so clear
you have to have boundaries that you
draw
and when you draw boundaries that has to
come with a or what sentence and or what
on the back end
you can't tell these jokes around my
kids anymore grandparents
or my kids will not be around you
I will make sure of that
you cannot hit me again or I will leave
and I'll be devastated and I will be
alone but I won't be getting hit
and you will sit down and say I need us
to build a new marriage and I want to
build something from scratch that
neither of us have ever seen before
and if he looks at you and says Ah I'm
good
that would be a devastating
shh and that's when you and your
counselor can have worked out the or
what and it doesn't have to be I'm
leaving it can be okay I'm gonna work on
new things I'm going to commit to not
yelling I'm going to commit to I'm gonna
commit to
foreign
s and that's it that's it
the or what is hard the award is scary
but that comes with every boundary
and probably for the first time in your
life you're
gonna peel back a lot of layers of
protection and a lot of layers of false
control and a lot of layers of a little
kid protecting you and you're gonna have
to ask yourself the scariest question
possible what am I gonna do next
hang on the line Elaine I'm going to
send you on your pass change your future
to be my gift to you and check it out
and I want you to read it I want you to
let me know how that goes
I'm proud of you for getting to this
moment
and I need you to hear me say clearly
you're worth going to sleep
you're worth laughing from your guts
you're worth a great marriage
and if you decide this guy's worth
um forgiving and letting him heal y'all
are worth building something new
together
and all of it starts today